e aí
a criança infância não são palavras
sinônimas e nem sempre caminham juntas
cada vez mais a infância vem sendo
invadida por um excesso de tarefas
atividades e cobranças que tem impedido
as crianças de viver o bem mais precioso
que é um momento presente com tempo
livre tempo livre para criar para
experimentar para inventar tempo livre
para um brincar livre
e quando eu tinha nove anos eu peguei
catapora tive ficar uma semana em casa
de repouso e não pude ir para escola eu
lembro da raiva e da frustração que eu
senti porque esse para mim era o pior
dos castigos eu amava e para escola
nesse ano de 2019 eu atendi três
crianças no meu consultório de
psicologia de idade entre 6 e 11 anos
que pegaram dengue e tiveram buscar uma
semana em casa de repouso quando elas
voltaram para o meu consultório eu
perguntei para cada uma delas e aí como
que foi está em casa uma semana de
repouso com dengue para minha surpresa e
tristeza essas três crianças de idades
diferentes contextos familiares
diferentes e escolas também diferentes
foi a mesma elas me disseram foi ótimo
porque eu não tive que ir para escola
quando eu escutei se eu tiver certeza
que a gente tá errando muito com as
crianças especialmente na educação tem
sido oferecida em grande parte dos
contextos escolares atuais eu tive a
sorte
boa sorte mesmo e o privilégio de
estudar numa escola em que até os meus
10 anos de idade eu não tive uma única
prova não foi eu não tive nota e muito
menos boletim eu fui descobrir o que era
um boletim na minha formatura da 4ª
série que hoje a gente chama de 5º ano
quando a minha professora me entregou um
envelope pardo com alguns papéis e
documentos e eu muito curiosa foi querer
ver o que tinha um desses papéis era um
quadrinho com o nome das matérias e os
números e eu e duas amigas fomos
perguntar para o professor que que era
aquilo e ele explicou que aquele um
boletim nessa escola que eu te dei até
os meus 10 anos de idade é a proposta no
máximo 15 alunos por turma a gente não
usava uniforme tem dia que eu ia para
escola de chinelo porque era assim que
me sentia à vontade era localizada numa
área verde privilegiada em nós alunos
nos beneficiará vamos muito disso a
maior parte dos meus recreios eu passei
no alto de pinheiros e goiabeiras
comendo goiaba do pé toda a sala tinha
uma horta eu tive várias aulas de
educação física nadando num riacho
subindo na montanha que tinha um
a escola eu aprendi sobre a metamorfose
do sapo observando girino que a gente
pegou do riacho dentro de uma quadra na
minha sala de aula as atividades ao ar
livre elas eram tão ou mais importantes
do que as atividades aconteceram dentro
de sala de aula nos eventos festivos
como o carnaval e festa junina toda a
ornamentação da escola até as nossas
fantasias éramos nós crianças que
fazemos não tinha nada feito por adulto
eu lembro no carnaval de quando eu tinha
8 anos a minha professora me perguntou
do que eu queria me fantasiar no desfile
que até na escola eu olhei para a janela
e falei de nuvem e ela me perguntou qual
o material eu precisaria para fazer a
minha fantasia eu comecei a listar papel
crepom azul claro azul escuro cartolina
fita crepe algodão e barbante no dia
seguinte estávamos todos na sala de
artes eu minha professora e meus colegas
cada um fazendo a sua fantasia eu tenho
certeza que a minha fantasia de nuvem
ficou longe de ser perfeita e
maravilhosa aos olhos
é de um adulto mas eu lembro a sensação
de satisfação e felicidade que eu senti
no dia do desfile porque tá usando uma
fantasia que eu e de eliseu e eu fico
com as minhas próprias mãos eu sair
dessa escola e fui para uma outra grande
tradicional conteudista com um monte de
prova semana de prova boletim uniforme
todo cinza mais de 50 alunos na sala eu
lembro da primeira aula de um professor
que ele começou a fazer chamada ele fez
mais ou menos assim ana beatriz você
número um breno você número dois carros
e número 3 e se você não veio sete eu
não tenho no meu caderno que era o
número 7 mas eu não fazia ideia do que
significava isso até até segunda aula
esse mesmo professor que ele chegou na
sala sentou na cadeira abriu o diário de
classe começou um número 1 2 3 7 e assim
foi até o 50 e poucos sem se dar ao
trabalho de levantar a cabeça e olhar
nos olhos de cada uma das crianças que
ele chamava por números
e é óbvio que eu estranhei para caramba
esse universo novo mas eu me deve ter
muito rápido porque se tem uma coisa que
eu trouxe a minha primeira escola foi o
prazer ea sede por aprender eu aprendi a
amar estudar também trouxe dessa minha
primeira escola a certeza de que o que
eu falava pensava e fazia era importante
digno de valor eu sair dessa escola
oi e eu pensei né quando fui escolher
uma profissão eu pensei eu quero uma
profissão e que eu possa trabalhar na
escola em que eu souber até os meus 10
anos de idade psicologia e uma das
minhas especializações foi na abordagem
centrada na pessoa de cal roger que tem
como um dos pressupostos a natureza
positiva do ser humano aqui na minha mão
eu tenho uma semente de girassol agora
queria conversar com você sobre semente
de girassol e bebês aqui na minha não
tem uma semente de girassol não sei se
vocês conseguem ver e eu queria dizer
para vocês que nessa semente aqui existe
um potencial de que isso que se torna
uma linda e a soberana e flor que é um
girassol mas eu pergunto para vocês eu
posso afirmar com toda a certeza que
essa semente aqui ela vai se tornar uma
semente de girassol não posso afirmar
porque eu não sei sobre quais condições
ela vai ser cultivada vai ser cuidada
para afirmar isso eu precisaria dizer eu
precisaria de saber que ela vai estar em
contato com a terra com a água com sol
no ambiente arejado
e nas quantidades ideais assim começa a
semente de girassol um bebê que tá
nascendo agora na maternidade ou em casa
no parto domiciliar ou em qualquer outro
lugar ele traz com ele potencial
positivo de crescer e se desenvolver de
uma forma madura e positiva do ponto de
vista físico emocional social e
cognitivo ele tem uma tendência
auto-realização e assim começa a semente
de girassol um bebê que tá nascendo
agora ele precisa de determinadas
condições para que aliadas as suas
possibilidades internas essas
características inatas ele possa se
desenvolver e se tornar uma criança um
adolescente e um adulto feliz seguro
auto confiante resiliente flexível
criativo proativo que vai cuidar desse
do mundo do qual ele faz parte o mundo
em constante transformação e é um pouco
sobre essa algumas dessas condições que
eu preparei a minha fala para vocês aqui
hoje eu uso eu dizer que educar uma
criança nos dias de hoje é uma ciência
exata e matemática
e eu preparei algumas fórmulas de
matemática para contar para vocês
algumas dessas condições que se
oferecidos e proporcionadas para uma
criança de uma forma persistente e
consistente vão se tornar um terreno
fértil para que se beber se torna todo
seu potencial que é positivo a primeira
forma essa aqui expectativa é igual a
frustração ao quadrado mais raiva essa
fórmula na verdade ela é de autoria de
dois ciclos queridos de belo horizonte
antónio coppi que foi meu professor e
maria luíza rocha e o que que significa
dizer isso significa dizer que toda vez
que eu cria uma expectativa em relação
aos meus filhos seus sua mãe seja em
relação a como serão fisicamente como
serão relação temperamento personalidade
o desenvolvimento aprendizagem a chance
de ouvir frustrado duplamente sente
raiva é quase certa eu lembro da
gestação da minha primeira filha de uma
gravidez maravilhosa muito saudável eu
fazer atividade física regular meditava
fazer yoga entoava manter antes de
dormir
o teu no parto natural na água
maravilhoso com meu marido do lado uma
suíte de parto como a luz preparada para
isso com músicas que eu selecionei que
me conectavam com a minha feminilidade
com a minha ancestralidade feminina eu
fui assistida por dois profissionais
sensacionais autor em questão maggioni e
além da bezerra e obstetra minha doula
são pessoas que sabem como proporcionar
um parto humanizado independência
natural normal ou cesariana e eu criei
muita expectativa em relação a minha
filha eu queria minha expectativa de que
ela seria um bebê muda você sabe que eu
bebê blusa é um bebê que nasce chora um
pouquinho mama dorme acorda rir mama
dorme acorda dorme e minha filha foi
encontrado o bebê buda ela chorava para
caramba e eu lembro que eu fiquei muito
frustrado e morri de raiva sentia raiva
de mim porque não conseguia acalmá-la
errado aquele bebê que não parava de
chorar ali eu cobri conectei com algo
crucial na educação de filhos os nossos
filhos não serão que nós esperamos que
eles sejam eles serão que eles são
simples e profundo
é uma criança que cresce sentindo
verdadeiramente aceita de uma forma
positiva incondicional como ela é é uma
criança que vai crescer se sentindo
feliz e segura a sendo ela mesma isso
não tem preço a segunda forma que eu
preparei para vocês essa aqui quanto
menor a minha disponibilidade física e
emocional para os meus filhos e isso é
igual a maior show mais quantidade de
choro bia e conflito na minha relação
é a que são insensíveis ela se conecta
com a nossa energia elas capitão nossa
frequência e respondem prontamente a
isso se comportando eu lembro quando
minha filha tinha dois anos ela me
acordou no sábado de manhã era domingo
de inverno frio para caramba a 6 horas
da manhã me acordou com sede de mim de
vida de brincar de cantar eu levantei
super contrariada com dor de cabeça com
raiva de tarde acordada sentei no chão
para brincar com ela mas o meu coração
minha cabeça tava lá na minha cama no
meu edredom no meu travesseiro e ela no
auge os seus dois anos de idade se
conectar com a minha responsabilidade
emocional e respondeu prontamente a isso
você ferramentas que ela tinha se
comportando atuando a raiva ea
frustração dela fez birra jogou os
brinquedos para o altas maior bagunça eu
fico uma raiva danada mas ele não
entende que muitas vezes o comportamento
desafiantes da minha filha diz de mim
diz da minha disponibilidades a minha
pouca entrega e uma forma de resolver
resolver isso é só inverter um pouco os
termos essa fórmula quanto maior a minha
responder
é isso que emocional para os meus filhos
menor menor gostar de choro de birra e
de conflitos em casa a terceira forma
forma matemática é o excesso de telas
celular tablet computador televisão é
igual a menor quantidade de qualidade de
sono menor abertura para realização das
tarefas do dia-a-dia e menor a busca por
relações sociais é bem importante falar
que do lugar emocional e psicológico que
as células o mundo virtual ocupa na vida
de uma criança a criança as telas a
tecnologia ela atua na área de prazer do
cérebro em desenvolvimento e uma criança
gosta o tempo todo se sentir amada
aceita ela busca pertencer e ela usa se
sentir importante em tudo que ela faça e
na ausência de pessoas para
proporcionarem possibilitar e isso é as
telas tecnologias elas ocupam esse lugar
de uma forma muito potente além disso a
chance de uma criança se tornar
dependente das tecnologias ela é real a
organização mundial
você já reconhece a dependência as
células tecnologias como uma doença
psiquiátrica atual e crescente uma
criança que fica tempo demais nas telas
é uma criança que vai apresentar um sono
mais conturbado em menor quantidade é
uma criança que vai tá menos aberta -
pronta para as tarefas e atividades do
dia a dia e uma criança que vai buscar
cada vez menos a relação com o outro
porque a relação com outra me demanda
empatia flexibilidade me demanda te dar
um trabalho que o mundo tecnológico
virtual cheio de prazeres imediatos não
proporci ona
e a quarta forma matemática eu trago
essa tempo de qualidade com mãe e pai
mais contato com a natureza mais tempo
livre é igual a saúde física e emocional
ao quadrado
e as crianças têm sede de relação
especialmente com as pessoas são
importantes significativas para elas
como pai a mãe e os cuidadores e ela tem
que ser de relação com que intimidade
uma relação com intimidade ela requer
tempo olho no olho toque conexão sobre
isso eu lembro de um cliente que atendi
no meu consultório há um tempo atrás uma
criança de 5 anos filho do meio de três
filhos chegou meu consultório trazido
pelos pais que tinha um certeza que era
uma criança que tinha algum grau de
autismo eu tive algumas sessões para ser
criança e não identifiquei absolutamente
nada que pudesse me dizer que era uma
criança que tinha esse diagnóstico mas
eu deixei que tinha uma carência afetiva
tremenda e eu prescrevi para esse casal
tempo de qualidade com esse filho eu
propus que por um amanhã ou semana tem
tempo indeterminado o pai e a mãe se
ausentassem do trabalho para cuidar do
adoecimento emocional desse filho que se
ausentar sem para sentar brincar olhar
nos olhos tocar dar uma volta no
quarteirão de mão dada os pais levaram o
maior susto mas toparam
há semanas a mãe me ligou emocionado a
dizendo para outra criança e que ela
tava revendo toda a vida dela
profissional especialmente o tempo que
ela passava ou não passava com os filhos
dela presença de qualidade de mãe e pai
cura os sintomas que as crianças vem
desenvolvendo para sobreviver às
condições adversas esse mundo doido e
cheio de cobrança que nós adultos
estamos em ponto para elas além disso as
crianças são seres naturais ela se
beneficiam se acalmam e se abastece em
contato com elementos naturais terra
grama sol chuva árvore plantas e
pequenos animais e o tempo livre ele é
vital para criança primeiro porque ela
descansa ela precisa descansar segundo
porque ela precisa assimila aquilo que
ela aprendeu e terceiro porque ela
precisa ressignificar e elaborar as
experiências do dia a dia delas sejam
positivas ou negativas e uma nação se
crianças têm de elaborar as suas
experiências através do brincar livre
mas para criança brincar ali na precisa
de ter tempo livre uma
os três elementos é uma criança que vai
desenvolver de uma forma positiva
fisicamente emocionalmente
é a última forma matemática eu trago
para vocês ela traz aquele famoso menos
com menos dá mais das equações segundo
grau de matemática vocês lembram eu
nunca mais esqueci nunca mais esqueci
porque é naquela escola onde era o
número 12 quando eu tinha 12 anos eu
fico é onde o número 7 quando eu tinha
12 anos aqui uma prova que eu usei toda
a folha de uma prova para fazer uma
única equação de segundo grau o meu
cálculo foi perfeito mas na última linha
coloquei - 2 - 3 = - 5 e a resposta
certa é mais cinco o professor pegou a
renata vermelha ele fez um x todo o
tamanho escreveu o número zero ainda
fica por extenso zero e ainda pois um
ponto exclamação tudo de vermelho quando
eu receber a prova eu olhei para que eu
olhei para o professor ele conseguiu
três coisas com isso ele conseguiu que
tivesse ódio daquele ser humano diante
de mim ele conseguiu que eu passasse de
testar equação do segundo grau e ele
conseguiu que eu nunca mais esqueci que
menos com menos dá mais se era isso que
ele queria ele conseguiu né eu queria
dizer para você zé quanto menos
atividades as crianças
ah e quanto menos bens materiais
presentes comprados para compensar
talvez uma ausência de pai e mãe que
trabalham muito e significa uma maior
possibilidade da criança vivenciar o que
realmente importa que são contatos de
uma proximidade uma leveza de uma
simplicidade no mundo onde as relações
não estão tão distanciadas afetivamente
buscar o exato é se conectar com simples
com natural seja no parto seja na
comunicação seja na rotina se conectar
com buscar o exato e se conectar com a
perspectiva da criança criança que eu
fui criança que você foi e que
provavelmente estão sendo dela pelas
durezas e cobranças em excesso desse
mundo adulto muito obrigada
e aí